طيب على الجانب الاخر هل تعتقد او كيف
تقيم لي زياره التي قامت بها رئيسه المفوض
الاوروبيه الى واشنطن ولقائها بالرئيس جو
بايدن هل قربت الاتحاد الاوروبي اكثر
للاصطفاف وراء واشنطن في الصراع مع الصين
لا اعرف ان كانت الصين هي محور هذه
المحادثات
او ان كانت ضمن الاولويات
اغلب السياسات
كانت ملصقه فيما يخص اوكرانيا ولكن اوروبا
التمضي في نفس اتجاه الولايات المتحده وهو
عدم مواجهه الصين ولكن مع الادراك بان
الصين لديها سلوكيات او بعض سلوكيات غير
المقبوله
وبالتالي هم في منافسه تتطلب منا
الاستجابه
وهنالك حركه كبيره على الاقل من الجانب
الاوروبي ولو فقط عبر الخطاب او الكلام
ولكن
اعتقد
بان هنالك اتجاه موحد على الاقل عبر
الاطلسي بس يعني انت ذكرت بانه ما كانت
للصين اولويه لكن تم نقاش مساله
التكنولوجيا والاتفاقيه تحدثت عن نقل
التكنولوجيا بحيث تشكل درعا امام الصين
او درعا امام تكنولوجيا الصينيه اذا الصين
كانت في صلب الاحداث او في صلب النقاش
هذا صحيح
[موسيقى]
هنالك زياده في الفرد الضوابط على التصدير
او التجاره